>>DANIEL FRIEDMAN: That was
just Bleu's entry music. Hello and
welcome, everyone, to ActInf Lab
Livestream number 036 Dot One. It's
January 19, 2022.
Welcome to the ActInf lab. We are a
partner participatory online lab that is
communicating, learning, and practicing
applied Active Inference Lab. You can
find us at the links here on this slide.
This is a recorded and an archived
livestream, so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve our
work. All backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome and will be following good
video etiquette. For live streams. You
can check Active Inference Lab.org to
learn about how to participate in any
active lab events which go beyond but
also support the live streams. And also
the Coda site at the bottom will give
you access to the table with metadata on
the past and ActInf Livestream. All
right, today in Active stream number 36
one, we're going to be discussing and
learning and seeing who joins for the
paper. Modeling ourselves. What the Free
Energy Principle reveals about our
implicit notions of representation by
Sims and Pazulo. 2021 we
went over some of the background in 360,
and today we're just going to introduce
ourselves, say hello, what we were
excited about in the paper. And then we
wrote down some things to discuss. But
I'm sure both of you have other random
things you wrote down. And anything that
people write in a live chat, we can also
look at. So I'm Daniel. I'm a researcher
in California, and I think I'm excited
to just hear Dean's marginal comments
and just see where it goes, because
there's just a lot in this paper and so
it'll be a thick one.
>>> DEAN TICKLES: Well, I'm Dean. I'm here in
Calgary, and I really didn't know
if I even had time to even look at this
paper. And then I listened in on Daniel
and Bleu's conversation in the zero,
and it piqued my interest. And so
I read the paper and I was
really happy to read this paper because
where Daniel and Bleu kind of took
a path to introducing the material,
this is kind of familiar ground,
familiar territory for me, which is very
unusual because most of the stuff that
we look at, I'm looking at it for the
first time. And so I'm really excited,
and I don't want to detour anything that
you guys want to sort of look at. At the
.1, maybe at the .2 point of
this process, we can look at section
five of this paper. What can we learn
from this debate? Because I think that
section five of this is super
interesting and not just trippy. You
guys use the word trippy, which I
thought was fantastic, quite a good
description. But I think we can pull
parts of this out and look at them
and reassert them and reattach them in
our own way and actually come up with
something pretty amazing. I'll pass
it down to Bleu.
>>> BLEU KNIGHT: Hi, everyone. I'm Bleu. I'm a researcher
in New Mexico. And this paper was
great. Like Dean was saying, it was
familiar to me, but not because of my
background. I thought it really
explained and summarized a lot of like
different points in the FEP active
Inference lab and how we use it to model
ourselves. And it pulled out
a lot of really important questions, I
think, that I'm looking forward to
discussing with you guys.
>>> DANEL: So we wrote down some things to discuss,
but maybe let's start with just a blank
slate. Dean, what do you think would be
some approaches that we can take or some
starting points because we already have
other cards up our sleeve. Cell.
I don't want to be a guy holding up the
flag and detouring your conversation.
One of the things we might get to near
closer to the end, hopefully, is the
authors speak to the possibility of,
you know, when you set up your table.
>>> DEAN: Daniel, one of the things that they
potentially talked about in the section
five of the paper is the idea that the
lines are a little bit fuzzy here,
maybe they're broken. And the idea of,
in some cases our ability to move from
internal representation into the
representational. It's kind of a big
deal because you can have the debate
that says here's the parts that would
align with a non representational view
and here's the parts that would align
with a representational view. But then
they insert this part that says but
maybe we slip into and out action action
action action action, action oriented
representation into and out of the cue
density. And so maybe at near closer to
the end today, we can tap into that a
bit.
>>> DANEL: Let's start with that grid.
Yeah, because this is the structure of
the paper and the elucidating
contribution. And also I think Dave
left to YouTube comment or something
like there's other dimension. So this is
kind of pointing away towards an
interesting approach to making
sense of some philosophical debates,
kind of laying them out in tables like
this. So how
should we approach it? There's the
representational and the
nonrepresentational perspectives or
stances or modes or archetypes that is
definitely very blurry because of course
it depends on what you mean by
representation and that can have some
fundamental ambiguity and then that
representational versus not continuum or
dialectic is then separated
into a few domain.
I think we could talk about what are the
similarities and differences because
some of it was a little nuanced and I
wondered if there was other categories
or they were organizational,
structural, content related and
functional. So then this is your game
board of eight lower dimensional
projections that the thought can be in.
Or it's something like one of these
eight octants.
And then a lot of the papers going
through some of the literature and
rhetoric for and against each of these,
using the FEP as kind of the interpret
what is being interpreted to speak for
one of those eight cells. Whether either
of you want to continue it there.
Well, on the Action D, Maisto that
sensory motor stuff and yelly,
bloomberg talks a good
argument around the idea that, for
example, I could be in a flow state and
there is no model or plan that I'm
necessarily following. And that's true
if we're talking about extension and
embedded as two of those four Es, you
don't necessarily have to move to that
place that requires something to work
off of. You could just be flowing and
working in something, right?
That rate of change is you extended.
>>> DEAN: So there are times when you've
you literally don't have to be working
off of a plan. You could also be moving
from a blueprint to some kind
of outcome that you want to achieve.
And then it's pretty obvious then that
the representational piece has to exist.
So maybe the argument isn't that
both aren't at work. It's how we
cognition from a density out of a
density and then back into a density,
something to at least have a
conversation about. Because I
think Bleu was touching on this last
time too. She said, I just want somebody
to be able to show me how these lines
are in this sort of structured
relationship exist. When I
heard her say that, I was kind of like,
no, I think that's a fair question
because those lines seem to be blurred.
>>> BLEU: So something that came up yesterday is
the idea of free will. And I just
wonder how that might play into these
different grid boxes.
Is there free will in all of
these or in none of them? Or is that
even relative?
>>> DANEL: Okay, let's write
it down.
One interesting thing about this is
it has a little bit of that visual
illusion with the black grid
and the white dots at the junctions.
So it's kind of a interoceptive artifact
just sort of messing with our visual
representation. And the visual
representations are when you see it,
you believe it that kind of focus system
in a lot of the active literature and
vision. Okay,
so let's save
free will and the blurriness for later
and then come to some of the things we
wrote down for the previous list.
Okay, so in what sense can or
are computational models or any other
kind of models be fully observable?
Can I give maybe a possible real
life example that maybe speak starts to
speak to that? Sure. Okay, so in
the paper, the authors say,
however, these differences matter if one
considers structural aspects and the
degree of resemblance between hidden
variables and environmental dynamics.
So I was thinking about your question,
and so I wrote this down. If dynamics,
then the material I e, the content, the
structure, and the organization is going
to have a different change rate than the
function. So the first three columns are
going to behave differently than the
fourth. For example, the screwdriver
as tool remains very stable, hopefully
relative to the spiral effect or
function that it can generate on the
screw to the one driving the screw.
There are now two rates to juggle the
assumptions that the tool applying the
function as a rule is stable and
consistent and the effect sought will
be a form change, meaning action
orientation, where a new representation
outcome happens. You quite literally
start an end with a dance between the
stabilities and the dynamics leveraging
off of each other. So back and forth.
So we need to keep open the possibility
that the stable or the representational
and the dynamic, which as Cell points
out, can be nonrepresentational as well,
are both in play. And then I wrote here
because I've used the expression when in
doubt, zoom in, zoom out. When Markov
blanket zoom in, zoom out.
So in terms of the computation,
there's actually two computations.
One around what we think should remain
relatively consistent and one which we
then apply that consistency to
something that we actually want to see a
rate change expedited.
So there's actually I think there's two
calculations here to the person that's
trying to figure out how
they're going to see
what's on the other side of the blanket.
>>> DANEL: Very interesting. Lorenzo Laje.
>>> BLEU: I like this idea of zooming in and out
with a markup blanket and I think it
speaks to the way that agent
are nested or anything is
nested. I don't want to necessarily
ascribe agency or free will to different
levels of organization, but I think
when Markov blanket zoom in different
Markov blankets, zoom out different
Markov blanket. So for me it speaks to
multi scale systems and how
applying markup blankets is kind of
scale friendly or imputed onto the
system in question.
One extension or maybe example of that,
we've probably talked before, like the
table, it's in the process biology,
it's material that's tabling, but then
that Attial is also process based. So
sort of this multiscale process ontology
and the identification of a given system
of interest. At stationarity like an
object that can be tracked, but there's
objects that are too fast to be tracked
and there's objects that are too slow to
be tracked below the just noticeable
difference. And so within a given
measurement or active inference regime,
a given entity can have attention on
a given system of interest. It can't
have attention on things that are slower
or faster, like out of its frequency
band. But that's discarding
99% of the system to not
consider outside of the frequency bands.
It's like the observables are just one,
they're very boundary and so the
slower things are, the larger things and
the faster things are, the smaller
things. So that's kind of
a nice.
And. Let me just piggyback on that.
And if we're talking about specificity
or scale friendly
versus cosmic
and scale free, that's also part of that
zoom in, zoom out exercise because there
are quite literally elements of this
that are still scale free.
Again, as they said, modeling ourselves.
We can start from that position of scale
free and then find the specifics, or we
can find the specifics and ask ourselves
how far out can we extend our
confidence that the stability will hold?
So that's, again, piggyback on what you
just said, Daniel. There are all kinds
of ways of interpretation zoom in and
zoom out. And I think that's maybe
that's one of the insights that we
get when we don't get ourselves hung up
on being a really radical enactivism.
Even though I'm of the camp that says we
start out internal representation, an
activity leaning side, and then the
plans and the representations and the
effects of that are representational.
All right, I'll think of an example that
a wet lab example. So I'm thinking of
doing PCR or a wet lab technique where
you're not observing perhaps the
outcomes of what's happening for
multiple steps. And even then it might
be a color change or a number on a
screen. And so then you get limited
observables. Those are sometimes your
degrees of manipulation, like in a
thermocycler that's changing the
temperature. The only thing you're
measuring during the reaction is the
temperature. Sometimes you might also
look at like the optical property, but
usually just changing the temperature.
And then it's very representation like
to have a mental or cognitive
representation, which can include
extended phenotype like the notebook and
the computer. But that's pretty
representational to have counterfactuals
about what molecules would do that have
never been visually observed.
And so science becomes
representational. And I think how
far does that reach back? And it kind of
blurs off into increasingly internal
representation forms. Not saying that
science is the most representational
thing, but what are the most
representational things? Back and forth
on that is what I'm seeing with the 2ft
in, 2ft out. But you just hit on a
really important point because you said
science becomes so what makes up
the becomes like, what exists in
that space prior
to it us all agreeing that it's now
science. And I think that's what this I
think that's what this modeling as
opposed to us as model asks
us to consider. You touched
on the big deal here,
Abductively. So what makes
up that? What has to be present for us
to be able to say, okay, now you've
crossed a threshold and now we're
talking science?
Yes. It reminds me of the
paper of Brunberg anticipating brain
is not a scientist. And we can just take
the always prescient titles and content
of these papers to be targeting
attention point like is the Markov
blanket a valid or useful construct?
More recently, but back several years
ago, identifying some similarities or
at least an area
of interaction with the
anticipatory and cybernetics of systems,
which is pretty system agnostic, can
apply to very abstract representations
as well as perhaps real systems. And
then the physical brain hypotheses and
the inactivist and ecological
perspectives on cognition with this
activity called science and the role of
a scientist. And so a few
ways to parse science. One is,
as we heard from Majid Beni recently
with model based science. So that's
one relevant way that we learned
about it and talked about this recently,
like science being the application of
models, but then other systems
are perhaps doing something different.
Well, what is science? Anyone in the
live chat should definitely respond,
what is science? And also, I would like
to hear what both of you think and how
that relates to anything we're talking
about here or ever. So I always
think about science as the implication
of the scientific method to anything,
right? So observations, hypothesis,
experiment, etc. Force.
And because I think of science like
this, science itself is just a
model also, right? So we use science.
We build a model of whatever phenomenon
it is that we're trying to replicate or
observe or test or whatever. And we
do. We experiment with our model,
essentially. So the scientific method
itself is a model for doing science,
and then the process of doing it is
creating a model of the world. So it's
like nested models all the way down in
science in my world.
So, Bleu, can I ask you a quick
question? What do you think precedes the
engagement with what you're describing?
Because the authors always say
assumptions matter. What assumptions do
you think goes into a person saying,
okay, well, now I'm going to use
scientific method?
Are there things priors that we should
sort of pull out and examine that are
consistent when a person gets to a place
where they say, okay, I'm going to do
that? Yeah.
So there's a lot of stuff that's in the
scientific method. When I say the
scientific method, it encompasses things
like scientific bias and positive
control and a negative control. And so
all of these things are kind of this in
this umbrella category. When I say
scientific method and experimental
design is not always simple, but
definitely what precedes any science
happening is simply observation.
You have to be observant and to have
conversation. You have to have some
instrument with which to measure or
gauge the phenomena which you're trying
to examine, right, even if it's just
your brain, which is probably the most
powerful instrument of all of the
instruments, because it's fundamental to
any testable instrument that
tests anything in the world like
that. So that's a lot of priors, I
think. So is it fair to say then,
that to get to a place of adopting
a scientific method, one might first
possess before they can actually get
into the formalities of that, a field
seeking curiosity and a way finding
bias? And those are two different
things, right? One is, I can be a
spectator. The other one is, I've got to
get in the boat. I've got to get my skin
in the game. Do you think that those two
things are necessary to
adopt scientific method or to
commit to scientific method.
So I'd like for you to unpack those a
little bit more. Can you just describe
what you mean about, like those two,
the way finding and the curiosity?
Yeah, the field seeking curiosity.
Well, curiosity, I mean, it's kind of
got four parts. There's an epistemic
piece, there's a sensing
piece. I can't remember what the other
two are right off the top of my head.
But bottom line is the curiosity, it's
not sort of a monolith part
of that determination
because you don't know, but you're
prepared to put in some time and effort
to get past. Not knowing means that you
can take one of two essential paths you
can find out. Right. You can go to a
source that already knows where you can
figure out based on sort of
collecting and curating evidence.
So that's the field seeking piece
wait. What'S the difference between
finding out and figuring out? Like, to
me those are the same. So like, whether
you're collecting evidence from Google
or from that's epistemic. Right? But to
figure out is to not
have a source already, not a single
source of truth. That would be the
difference. So one, you can
find a truth source and then either
believe it or not. And the other is you
have to develop your own truth through
it takes a lot more time because you
have to go around and gather a whole
bunch of other bits of information that
aren't necessarily prepackaged for you.
Does that make sense? Yes. And also,
like, what is truth? Right? I mean, you
ultimately have to be the one that
decides that, right? Whether to trust
and have confidence in something or not.
Cool. Lots of really go
for it. No. Go ahead, Daniel.
So let's pull one level back
or two from one and a half fractal
dimension. From the curiosity fourfold
distinction, there was like the personal
factors. So the question was what
precedes the type of engagement that
might be called scientific? And there's
some personal factors that are basically
psychodynamic or like situational
behavioral archetypes, but there are
things about individual people,
humans. What other kind of factors,
even if the individual is the nexus of
agency, what other factors come into
play? And like, what precedes the kind
of engagement that might be called
scientific? If the person is our system
of interest, how do we zoom in and out
from there?
Cell that's my question. My question
isn't I don't have an answer
necessarily, but what I leave it to
before the big bang kind of thinking,
we don't know. But is it possible that
there actually is something that we can
put our finger on that leads someone to
have confidence in a scientific method
and not just sort of remain kind of in a
place of stasis and not be curious?
Right? Because there's lots and lots of
people who are kind of quite comfortable
just going along with whatever is
happening around them but then there's
others that appear to have a
potential for a deeper commitment. So
for example when we were talking prior
to magic coming with us on with us,
Bleu raised the specter that
genes don't necessarily have to have
time in order to be considered
prediction matter expertise because it
has both the cause and the effect
included in the structure.
So that got me curious, right? For some
people just making that statement or
asking that question blow right by them,
they wouldn't even give it a second
thought. But then for some people just
making that claim arrests them, slows
them down and gets them asking questions
on their own. Now so that's why I'm
asking this in the context of so why
would somebody now go from I
don't care, I don't give a rats backside
about science to I'm very passionate
about science and I'm very interested in
learning this method.
So I think science really is seen by
many as a kind of truth finding endeavor
because whether it's through mining
previous knowledge or generating new
information, maybe knowledge,
either one of those is definitely like a
speaking of the truth.
And in that way aren't we all just
looking to minimize our uncertainty,
reduce our uncertainty? So I look at
science, it is an uncertainty reduction
task. I mean that's the point of it
perhaps. So I don't know what factors
other than the fact that maybe we're in
a simulation like we could go there
because that would precede the
scientific endeavors that we undertake
in our truth finding efforts.
But really the knowledge of science as
a way to determine truth I think might
be part of it and maybe not everyone has
taught that I think about like, you
know, in western culture we're all like
indoctrinated with the scientific method
from I don't know, fourth grade on or
something like that, right,
indoctrination.
And then they give you the PhD at the
end when you're fully indoctrinated.
But here's the thing Bleu and this is
but you bring up a really cool point in
fourth grade indoctrination. And I think
one of the things you and I have kind of
gone revolving back and forth is so,
yes, science. And so somebody has said
this has got some practical things and
some truth finding things. But I've
always come back with great science
plan. These are material things. My
question has always been when? And you
bring up the well we've decided when
it's grade four but I'm not sure
that someone who's graph four least me
see that'd be about 910 years of age.
It's the same sciences for somebody
who's 29 30 or 39 40, right.
So we can save clients now
but what I'm suggesting is that before
the plan or the science there's
something before that some really
important things that we're just
assuming or willfully ignoring
because now we're onto the plan, right?
Because that's what has been reified and
given the holy blessing sort of
thing. So I think you're hitting
something that's critical and it's why
I'm disagreeing with you. So I don't
think that the science that you're doing
when you're nine is that different from
the science that you're doing when
you're 39. And the perfect example
of that is Feynman I was reading I don't
remember, maybe it's in the meaning of
it all, like, maybe it's in that book,
but he talks about how, like,
for him, he just plays, right? And so a
lot of his science is like, oh, I get to
make this toy and play with it and try
to look at it. And I keep playing with
it and I keep playing with it. And so
this is something, I think, that's
innate in us to just the figuring out
part, like the truth finding part. So
even as a baby, like, from the time you
can sit up, like, what is this block?
Like, what is this shape, what is this
flinky? Right? It's finding out and
figuring out what are the affordance of
the objects. Some of them are
imposed by the outside. Like, don't
stand on the chair because kids will use
chairs as tents and step tools.
Some of it we impose some structure on.
You can't use this toy in that way, but
really, like, kids will they don't know
they'll use anything anyway. Like they
do all kinds of crazy things, like
they'll slide down a mountain on
a trash bag or something, right? So they
don't know what the limits
are and so they'll explore new limits.
And I think that scientists, at least
the ones that really leave to do
science, play a lot also.
So, again, the trial and error piece can
be like the triangles piece. It can be
scale free. And I would never push back
on that piece. The Epistemic
and the specific is what you just
described. The other two parts of
curiosity are the distributed and the
sensing. And that's kind of the sort of
the more active part where
you have to kind of go out and do the
skin in the game. You have to get in,
get in the boat across the South
Pacific. You can be doing the epistemic,
value the specific as well because you
can be taking samples, but you
can kind of see that there's another
side to this. So my question around the
when isn't around the ability
to see the scale free part of it. My
question is, if I'm a ten year old and
there's something before the plan, how
sophisticated is that something relative
to the something before the plan? As a
40 year old, I just don't think that the
experiences that a ten year old has and
the resources that they necessarily draw
upon are the same. So I do think there's
also a specific and a scale friendly
part to this. Would you push
back on that?
I mean, I think that we all kind of just
operate on whatever level. I do
agree that the knowledge of a ten year
old isn't the same as the knowledge of a
40 year old, but I think we
just operate at whatever level that
we're at. Similarly, like a baby, you
know, like they're just doing their own
kind of truth finding. But so the
process is the same. Like even though a
priori may differ, I think the process
is similar. This reminds me of
indeed linguistics guest stream with
Elliott Murphy, how there's the view of
language as the construct, like subject,
verb, object, and then there's the
language as learned by each learner.
And so I'm almost hearing like Bleu
saying it's the same process.
Everyone's on the same trip, but of
course recognizes that each learner is
going to have individual factors,
including like, what they specifically
know maybe has some correlations or
whatever with age or with other
features. And then that's I feel like
maybe partially reflected with the
specific of the curiosity is
the nine year old and a four year old
learning the same science.
It's either like pansy's or unisollopism
scientism. Everybody's in their own
scientific niche. And so it's just a
million different granules. And then the
other hand, the other end of that
extreme debate would be it's all one
integrated, extended cognitive process,
which I wrote some notes on. So Dean go
for that and then we'll think about it
as more of an extended continuum
process. Yeah, and again, I'm not
trying to I don't want to sort of
shoehorn something in here.
So I would always hear from people in my
history the expression,
well, I know that's a problem there. I
guess you're just going to have to get
creative. You're going to have to think
outside the box. And being the insurgent
and the non compliant person that I
am, I would say I would come back with
and I was reporting to people I would
come back with, so tell me about this
box. What makes up the box, what makes
up the process? And of course,
that didn't make me very popular because
nobody could get specific about what's
inside or what makes up that three
dimension space.
And I think it's the same thing with we
can say, well, there's a process. Well,
tell me then why a
ten year old thinks in the same way as a
40 year old Dutch. What evidence?
What are you hooking that assumption on?
And again, I'm I'm not, not trying to be
a pill here. I'm really curious. What
would make a ten year old think the
same way as somebody with an additional
30 years of experience?
They want uncertainty reduction.
That's a generalization that I can agree
with. But what about the specifics?
I'll give a specific in general. I think
that for disciplinary education, some of
the questions might be very. Similar.
Like why is this leaving group superior
to that one in organic chemistry? I
think if somebody were very precocious
in ten and learning about the halodes as
leaving groups or if they were learning
about it in adult education, they would
ask that question and then once they got
the answer, they would have moved on in
their learning in that disciplinary
finding out way. Like here's the
periodic table, here's why the trend is
this way. So that's not the whole of
education, but in that mode which
many of us have come from and exist
within, that was the education,
that's educational instruction.
So that's the instructionism component
and then I think it becomes different as
you move away from that spotlight.
So then a few other comments about the
specifics of how the different age would
be different. There's the
biology of how the individuals would be
different, like in some
of their cognitive features, whatever it
meant for that person, from working
memory to the specific long term
memories and other capabilities, they
have perspectives they've learned about.
They're a different, complex system,
but they can be a complimentary part of
the system. Like older people providing
mentorship for younger people. But I
think that's what kind of comes to some
of these notes on science as an extended
cognitive phenomena, which is partly
what has been got at.
So science has many different possible
goals and sometimes scientists in an ad
hoc way will appeal to different
components. Like science is correct
because there's technology, like it's
demonstrable or it's useful,
not always providing a Bull hypothesis
for what we would have if we had done
something different. But there are all
kinds of different ways to look
at it. But it deals with individual
cognition features and learning in
action in their niche. But it also
refers to broader phenomena. Like maybe
a differentiating question is can one
person on an island by themselves do
science? And if the answer is like yes,
they could explore a hypothesis test,
then that's one perspective. Another
perspective would be you're only doing
science when you're using this
interpretation of the scientific method
and you're using science as a body of
knowledge, like you're using the
literature with the dos. And some people
go as far to say that you need to have a
career in a certain specific institution
or a specific degree or a specific
training or approach. So that
is clearly not applicable to the one
person on the island. And not that one
of them is better, but that whole
apparatus, that's part of the extended
niche. And then also there's at least in
our case, the emphasis on the digital or
at least informational stigma g.
There's a cognition in science in a
different way than there's many books
you could read on tying knots, probably
a lot of YouTube channels.
Is there a DOI for information on knots?
Probably not, but that in
science is a big emphasis. Reading and
writing the literature, at least in the
way that we know it today. But again,
that could also perhaps not be as much
of a core component anyway, just like if
you point it maybe now we'll bring it
back to this paper. But science is
kind of the representational paradigm
and I think Dean's question is getting
at what is before? What's the before and
the after or the subconscious or the
submerged of science.
And when we're talking about that
representational piece and when we're
talking about science, we typically talk
in terms of isms what is where is
how is when we set up our hypothesis.
And I think, what this paper if we're
bringing it back to the paper, I think
what section five of the paper speaks
to, especially when we're talking about
the functional dimension, is the if,
the counterfactual, and how they talk in
there about how I'm not sure if it was
Clark or Hohwy or one of them talks
about the fact that so a bacteria
doesn't typically ask the question what
if?
When it's sampling its environment. So
that's pretty science.
Yes. And I think that relates a lot to
Martin Boots's guest stream, I think
twelve on the event based cognition and
how if there is an event based structure
to cognitive events then for any
given parameter in that model it can be
otherwise you could say like the ball is
rolling off a table. The ball is not
rolling off the table, the cup is
rolling off the table. Like you can
start to just do single mutations,
especially the important counterfactuals
for linguistic structures.
And then that might be closer
to what we've seen discussed in other
Sims papers as the adaptive active
inference agent. Going back to earlier
paper citing that but just that was our
previous discussion with Sims. This
paper has sims, like the pendulum,
does not have a counterfactuals about
whether it could go on a different axis.
It's mechanically constrained whereas
cognitive structures can engage in
counterfactuals play in a way that
the pinball machine can't. Even if the
pinball machine has chaotic or other
types of seemingly agency behavior.
In that space, I can be at the top of
the ski hill prior to a
gradient descent and I can be adaptive,
meaning I can close my eyes and do a
visualization. And I can also be
variational, meaning that I can try to
recreate through my interoceptive
sensors a sensation of floating pre,
pushing off and engaging with that
process. Right. So again,
the win of this, I think is something
that really matters. I think we gloss
over it or we don't even pay any
attention to it typically because we
want to get to in the paper it's figure
two. We want to get to figure two. But I
think before there was a figure two,
before there was a plan or a
representation, we might want to
ask when plan if I'm engaging in
counterfactual inference prior then
doesn't everything in the diagram depend
on prospecting up the nodes in that
representation? All right,
do I not have to provision up a format
that will be potentially something that
others can comprehend as now organized?
And don't I have to propose alternative
paths? As Ines, like, all of those
things are pre planned, all of those
things have to be present prescience.
So we can say,
well, I'm not paying attention to that
now because I'm busy putting processing
something that I can now transfer to
other readers and viewers of this
diagram. But I think to ignore those
things is to ignore the difference
between a ten year old doing a science
experiment and a 40 year old doing a
science experiment. Let me
give one thought on that. It actually
speaks to this question of whether
science is the same for everybody or
different for everybody. Is this the
board exactly as laid out that everybody
has to play by that's like the game of
life, the board game, not the cellular
automata simulator, but the board game.
There's one path or there's limited
points of agency and then everybody on
the board on that layer, one is moving
through life on the same or on a
constrained set of trajectories. So it's
like are these the immutable railroads
of decision making and thought?
Or might other people have different
connections or different decisions or
totally different railroad stops or
different dimension or just represented
in a different format? Is it like,
well, here are the battle lines that are
always going to be the case for
philosophy and there's going to be some
people whose situation and
neurodiversity leads them to be on this
side or this quadrant or emphasize this
component, the regime of attention? Or
is even that layer shifting because
there isn't any stability to be found in
counterfactuals?
There you go.
Back to the questions.
It was a great early point about the
rates of change being different because
also that does at least talking about
rates of change kind of evoke numbers
gets the scientists excited because
could there be like a number? Could
there be a sentiment score? Or could it
be like, this sentence is totally
consistent with both, or it's
inconsistent with this? Could we
annotate the literature and measure or
do surveys or actually measure those
rates of change in individuals on their
learning trajectory or in fields?
How could it go from just being a really
insightful philosophy paper with a
lot of scholarship into being
something where we can use some numbers
or something? So I see the first three
columns, organization, structure and
content as the more stable.
I think you had another diagram where
you were showing that going out over
longer periods of time, right? So which
one do you think is the most rapidly
changing function?
Okay, so let's kind of recap them. So
organizational seems to be related to
the encapsulation the
organization like brain architectures
features of the world such that the
representation is separated from what is
represented. So like you could have
representation of the sun but then
that's very far physically from the sun.
The structural aspect is related to
representational vehicles toot toot that
are structurally similar to the state of
affairs in the world they stand for.
So that is the abstract structure of the
representation having some congruence
or isomorphism or similarity
to what is being represented.
This one is super dependent on the
definition of representation because
someone go well, you can't represent a
car in your head because your head is
not a car.
Content related having internal model
models that either encode environmental
contingencies or sensory motor
contingencies, specification or
description of how the world is taken to
be turned analyzed in terms of
correctness or truth.
So that seems to be more consistent with
the car content. You know, it's like the
YouTube content, the car content can be
represented if it stands for something.
The content of that message was an
invitation to the birthday party. So
that is related to the information like
the memetics, especially in an
actionable way and
then the functional role. This is where
we're going to highlight and hopefully
Dean, I want to hear a little more about
why this one is different. Supports
vicarious use before or in the absence
of external events, internal variables
of model that was discussed in the paper
a lot in the context of sensory motor
detachment and there have been some
blurry lines down there for sure, like
motor replay and preplay. So we know
that it is on the spectrum of existing
that neural dynamics but cognitive
dynamics involved during are involved
echoes or anticipations of them are
involved in the before and in the after
as well as counterfactuals before and
after. So what is happening with
internal representation and then maybe
how does it relate to active and FEP?
Yeah, so I know enough about dreams
and subconsciousness just us to get me
into trouble. But the first three when
we reorganize through our dreaming and
whatever those representations are or
internal representation spending on your
wish, those are all backwards looking
typically and then the functional that's
what segregates it out is it's forward
and backwards. So that's to me a huge
differentiator right there in
terms of how much or how long we
expect something to stabilize versus how
much we want to act on something and
generate that change or outcome that
we're seeking. That's why I get back to
that search field being different than a
framework.
Okay, it's a lot to think about but it's
interesting. The organizational
maybe there's some dissenting view from
this but this is related to how the
system is arranged. So this one
can be thought to be slowly changing
because we're talking about things which
means we're talking something that has
persistence and so the organizational
aspects of systems tend to be the
slowest changing perhaps like the
organization of the servers changes on a
very slow timescale relative to the
processor. Then the structural aspect
also it's very important that it has
persistent like storing a variable in
memory. Like you want things to stand
for each other for a long time. You kant
the DOI to be a representation of that
paper for a long time. Those are also
related to like it's sort of the
functional side of organization like
form and function a little bit. But I
know function is used later. So not to
confuse the term function, but this is
related to some of the performative
aspects of organization and
infrastructure and architecture. So
that's also like you don't want the
screwdriver to be a different thing in
your hands that's too slow. But maybe
it'd be cool if you could modify or
tweak the tool or like, you know,
unscrew it and bolt something in a
little slower to make it different. But
usually you don't want to change too
fast then.
But what about the content related?
This seems to be also changing somewhat
faster because environmental or
sensory motor contingencies that seems
like that could change on the fly and
then I agree that the functional role as
defined here like vicarious detachment,
including counterfactual and self
modeling counterfactuals, this is like
some of the most rapidly mutating.
But what do you think about content also
changing fast? Well, I think whenever
image a mistake and I accidentally hit
the Deneve button on my notes, how upset
I get because the stability of the
content is lost. So I actually
see it is still relatively stable as
opposed to something that's changing
rapidly.
So these four columns
here, there is a different temporal
aspect which relates to what you asked
earlier about when representation.
So instead of the possessive do
organisms have representations or the
identitarian action, action oriented
representation, the definitional, what
are representations? This is the
temporal or the dynamical when our
representations well, that's not
complete. You have to say what it is.
You can't just say when it is well,
couldn't you just flip the words?
Wouldn't it be just the other person's
perspective? You can't talk about is
without when, so why is that one okay?
Why are there papers about what is a
representation? What is it like to be a
bat rather than when is it like.
I don't think it has to be or I think
it's both. The other thing that I think
we need to maybe think about is
the first three tend to
be on a continuum that's orthogonal to
the fourth. I can organize, I can
structure and I can content build.
Function now is orthogonal stat I
will because it's going it's
used before. So again, back to that
temporal aspect, it's both.
And I wouldn't drop any of the four
columns. I'm just saying that I think
that the fourth column is maybe on a Y
axis relative to the first three that
are on the X plane.
Okay, a few notes here. So before or
in the absence of right now,
isn't it the case that usually
anticipation entails something being
both before and in the absence of I
wonder what it will be like when my
friend comes over. That's in the absence
of the event and it's a counterfactuals
before, but it may happen. It's a
prediction, it's an expectation and
maybe even active inference lab. It's a
preference. So I agree, like even the
way that the authors have written it,
these are related to architectural and
performative features of like
basically functional or structural
definitions of representations, what
they are, what they do. And then this is
even uses temporal words as well as
counterfactual words, though and those
are probably like used elsewhere in the
paper. But that's a very interesting
distinctions. And so it's like there's
our map, but how easy is it to just lay
out the map and go, all right, here's
Northern California, here's a map
instead of the temporal aspect.
And I think that also shines a light
actually on another feature of what
people would call science, which is like
science the metric system. And then,
okay, you've gone too far with the
metric dime, but then pretty much on a
lot of the other fronts, except in the
United States, the metric system has
hold as how people are sense making
in terms of like distance and time and
other units and that's chronos like
chronology and time in the decimal time.
And then kyros is like the timeliness
and there's other ways to think about
time. So we kind of open it up and it
just makes me wonder, okay, what else is
handed with the map? Is there a time
object? How do we share time along with
the map? Is that attention is focus
times, time Ines all these
other things? So how do we convey the
temporal aspect instead of just this
gene regulatory network or this is the
map here or the map and the math and the
territory, how do we bring the temporal
along?
I wonder about
the temporal also and especially now
that we're kind of delving into like
quantum aspects because the
simultaneous existence of more than one
state right, is possible. And so is
it possible to be like building and
executing your model at the same time?
Is it input then output? Is it always
sequential or is there some kind of like
simultaneous happening that's
going on there? I don't know. Oh, Bleu.
That's perfect. For the next question I
wanted to ask. So is one of the
assumptions here that there's a
continuum, like if then between
I can and I will, because this was a
debate that I got into with people
forever when I was in education, that
there's some sort of an assumption that
because I can, therefore I will. Well,
I wouldn't jump off a cliff even with a
parachute on. There's no will for me to
do that because that's just not my jam.
But orthogonally speaking, if
organization is on the X and structural
is on the X and content is on the X,
but functional is on the Y, now I can
separate the two things out. And as you
said, if I go back to the quantum level
now, I'm predecision branched in
that diagram, do you notice that the
diagram is basically unidirectional?
It's always heading to a particular
outcome. It's always I can make this
decision branch moment, therefore I will
arrive at representational or
nonrepresentational and I'm with
you. I'm not so sure that previous
to this that it isn't bidirectional, it
isn't function, it isn't orthogonal. I
think it could be all three of those
things.
Hello. Would you like to say anything or
can I? All right. Two points
I would be remiss not to make. First,
the Tetrahedron and fuller synergetics
gives us a mnemonic to have four spatial
dimensions. So this four column scheme,
all of them can be four intersecting
spatial dimensions. They're coordinated
at 60 degrees, not 90 degrees. And then
the second point is like this
onedirectional maze reminded me a lot of
the way that people study decision
making and path finding or figuring,
whichever 1 may be in ants, which is
there some laboratory maze, like a Y
maze or T maze or maybe some branch on a
tree in nature. And then for the
purposes of the science, so called the
paper, it's going to be like we counted
them as going down a certain branch,
making a decision at the node when they
went 5 branch point and didn't return.
So it's like this is the line that you
trip when it goes from zero to one on
that number. And that's what gets fed
into the scientific process and the
method and observations of the
literature and the statistics and all of
that. But then if you're watching the
ant or if you look at the video, maybe
they dwell at the node or they turn
around or they walk down one and then
they come back. Or like even they go far
down one and they come back. So it is
very interesting and it's a subtle
graphical point, but one that would be
almost seen as like, what do you mean?
How could these be undirected edges?
Well, what if we say, hey, let's start
at representational FEP, it's just where
we're going to start today, and then
let's pull back to the vicarious use of
variables. Now where can we go from
there to sensory motor detachment? Or we
can take no and all of a sudden we're a
internal representation FEP because
they're only one step away, because
they're both outcomes of the decision
about the vicarious use of variables.
So I hope those are some interesting
points and I think that relates a lot to
the discussions that we've been having
in.edu about cyclic curriculum.
And you touched on it I'm going to just
bring it I'm gain to reduce it. Not over
reduce it. I'm going to reduce it. To
your point, Daniel, there can be a yes,
there can be a no, and there can be a
maybe. The maybe part is what's being
left to out of this.
Cool. I'll read a comment from Serval in
the chat, who I was also thinking of
when we talked about like, science as a
human phenomena and all of that. I think
she'll have a lot to say on that.
Serval wrote, considering many world
hey, Dee, I'm going to read Serval's
comment. Considering many world type
theories, is it possible that can
entails will? It would be a distinctions
property, though, not a trajectory
property.
Okay. I have to think of that in terms
of how I set up entailment.
Maybe I'm not trying
to duck. I think there will be times
when my confidence, through my
ability to say that I've done something
before, leads me to a lower threshold
around will. But then sometimes it
doesn't. So I'm not
trying to be evasive, but I can think of
times when it can entail, and I can also
think of times when it very much does
not. So will,
it's a short English word. It could
refer to something that will happen,
like the ball will go to the bottom of
the bowl unless anything else stops it
from doing that, or it can refer to sort
of that motivational ecological energy,
which is related to agency. And so it's
kind of an interesting congealed
word because agency and will are
very related. And I'm
just trying to think if they're
positively related, like, to feel that
you have the choice is to have the
agency. And that can be seen as
willpower. Whereas willpower doesn't
come into play in situations where
there's no agency. If you just need to
sit in the seat on the airplane, it
doesn't require any willpower agency for
that action to occur. So I'm just
thinking about learning the
distributional property, like
counterfactuals, do we engage with them
as a possible cosmological reality,
like in the many world type theories or
just cognitive possibilities
so they can be engaged with without
taking on like a cosmological meaning?
And then what does that mean about RN
equals one trajectory, the specifics of
our kind of entity
in motion, and then the distinctions of
perhaps different types of
counterfactuals or different kinds of
possible stochastic rollouts of the
system given really similar starting
conditions. And that's where the will
can entail. The can. I can start out by
asking what if? But I still have to
select the can the which if
again, at some point we
can see a relationship of entailment.
But I think as a
quantum question, they're orthogonal.
Can and will are dot. One leads
necessarily to the other.
So just to kind of play on words and
loop back around to what I was talking
about earlier, can is an affordance.
Right. So if you have an affordance,
that doesn't mean that you'll use it.
Right. And will I will choose
or implies that you have some agency.
Right. I choose to not start
a fight with a flight attendant while
I'm sitting in my seat on the airplane
or whatever, because you can do all
kinds of things. You get many
affordance. And I
just wonder how this ties into these
representational and non
representational aspects of the FEP.
Like, really, when I was talking about
free will earlier, if interface states
are a direct representation of external
states, it seems to me like I kind of
feel like there's less options
there, whereas internal and external
states have coupled dynamics. That kind
of leaves some mystical
fluff outside that I can essentially
leverage with my own choice or something
like that. I mean, I don't know what to
call it. Mystical fluff. But it leaves
something unfed. Right. Like there's a
coupling. It's like a hidden there's a
hidden states there that are only that.
That's where I can impose my will cell.
I'm going to put that fluff on a
pedestal. I'm going to honor the fluff
because I do think that there are actual
times when the
ability not to be captured by our
observations is actually an advantage.
So mystical meh may be uncertain.
Yes. And are there advantages to that
at times? Yes. So we can call it
fluff, but I think sometimes we don't
pay it enough respect.
I think that relates to the cloud of
unknowing, which is perhaps a text if
somebody wants to go into a more
esoteric avenue. But I'd like to return
to the figure and ask what either of you
thought about figure one. How does that
play into this conversation we've been
having? Like, what does this entity and
action partitioning have to do with
science? Is this partitioning unique to
active inference or other partitioning
as possible? Does it could
it be another way?
I think this is a pretty stable
representation, and I think it
does honor to the scale
free aspects of what the free energy
principle is pointing to in terms
of a statistical pathway.
Yeah. I mean, how many debates and
uncertainties could be prevented by
saying this is a representation of an
entity and having people know what was
meant by representation. Right.
Because it's like, I made this
representation of an entity. I think it
does this useful thing. Those points
cannot be false.
They're assumptions by a person.
And what would be disagreed with that?
It's not a representation. Someone would
say there's a more useful representation
or more good, true, beautiful, simple,
but then let's see it and then we can
use science to compare representations
because that would be okay.
Right. And then you said it does honor
to the scale free. So the only thing
that kind of hints otherwise is the
person. And the world kind of gives a
scale indicator
for this model, but without that
iconography, it would be and
also adding in perhaps a legend or
description of what the edges mean
because it does say schematic of
reciprocal exchanges. And it uses
statistical vocabulary, but it also uses
actual, like, ontological vocabulary in
the terms of actuators. So are these the
physical things that are doing the
actuating, or are they the statistical
or informational exchanges? Or is this
the representation, the form of a
scientist model? So we're only ever
talking about scientists using these
models so we're only ever talking about
that kind of nexus where we're referring
to both loosely and so it shouldn't be
interpreted as either
of them specifically it's just dialogue.
There's a lot of ways to interpret what
the edges are and they might have
similar different labelings and
different schemes. But it is
statistical, it is quantifiable.
It'S amenable, it's a qualitative
topological partitioning that is
amenable and beyond to certain
quantitative analysis. Like if you can
draw it like that, you might be able to
do a Bayesian graph and then there's
software toolkits and there's
implementable algorithms and then there
might be some quite interesting
guarantees or tendencies with brain
architectures. For example, to perform
predictive processing or to have
learning anticipation of memory or to
engage in control or anticipatory
control. But that's definitely some
of the most core iconography that we've
seen. I mean, 50% of papers or what
cell find out Bleu have the action loop.
Because what's a little side hustle of
you Bleu got going here?
We're trying to read more papers
together and learn about
them. Okay, but it's interesting
how often this has come up. And
sometimes authors draw on the same
image, other times they do different.
And sometimes the arrows are just the
clock, like just a unidirectional flow.
Other times there are some bi
directional arrows and there
are several guest rooms on the more
technical aspects there. But let's
return to the general questions.
Anyways, anything else to say on figure
one, though? Like just on this? Like
what is this and how is it? I think it
represents better the Pyfixating
on the pot fly than it does on the
physics model. And so I think it's until
somebody, as you said, until somebody
comes along with a better
representation, one that seems to give
us the maximum amount of information
that we need versus the maximum
that we can handle. I think this is a
good rep. Great and
very satisfying conclusion.
Sorry I really think that what's
not shown in this representation and
what I feel like is always left out is
the fact that some
states are hidden, right? And so where
is the hiding here? What is hidden from
what in this? And so like the
sensory states we don't even know if we
perceive I mean we know that we all
perceive temperature differently some
people I'm cold in this room but many
people would be comfortable and some
people like. My favorite colors purple.
My daughter's favorite color is yellow.
So like we don't perceive things in the
same way. And so there's always
something hidden from everyone else.
And I think that this schematic kind of
leaves that out. I've seen the hidden
states represented well in other action
perception loops, but I think that it's
important to recognize what's obvious
and what's not. If I
could give one thought there, then Dean.
So I think there's two levels of like
what are the hidden states from the
perspective of the internal states, the
system of interest, the external states
are hidden states implicitly or
explicitly modeled, but they're the ones
that are never directly observable.
They're only observed through their
proxy sensory states and enacted or the
transition frequencies are modified
through policy selection, through
action. So within the model, within the
Tetrahedral, the hidden states are
relative to the internal states on the
other side of the Markov blanket. And
then there's like the implicit
Tetrahedral, which is like us modeling
this four field partitioning and then
everything that's not included as a
variable in that statistical model is
like implicitly a hidden state. But then
what is that? But then we'd have a
different model if it wasn't a hidden
states.
And the other thing I think is that the
vertical line between sensory states and
active states, if you tip that 90
degrees, it would look like a blank,
even though it has two points on the end
of it. And I think that blank is by
definition hidden states. It's to be
filled in. So I think again,
you can fill in the blank or you can
leave it blank and say because it's
blank, that is by definition hidden.
So another related point, thanks for
bringing that up, Dean, is there's
one edge that's not shown here but has
featured very importantly in recent
discussions on active and that's the
sigma or the mapping function from
number 26 and number 32, a mapping
function of internal states to external
states. Now look at Axel Constant and
Yellow Bernard's work to think about how
the niche is also doing like
anticipatory modeling of the individual.
So the other way, but let's just focus
on the entity and its mapping to
external states. It's predicting
external states or at least acting as
if, or can be modeled as if. So there is
an edge there that we've seen in modern
work, it's not drawn here, which
actually might suggest either the
inheritance of a legacy graphical
pattern or some preferences
or conclusions about what these edges do
represent, again, even though they're
unlabeled. So that's one edge that we've
been hearing more about. And then I
think another edge that Dean just
highlighted is this one directly between
sensory and active states. And again,
the clock flow doesn't have this, the
one that's just internal action,
external sense, that doesn't have the
sense action bridge. And it depends
a lot on what these things mean. But
it'd be cool to understand what is meant
by the backwards connections as well as
by the vertical connections. And why are
there not backwards connections between
action and internal and sensory and
external? It's like it's really a four
by four matrix with some connections.
And that's how we've seen it represented
as the sparse connectivity matrix in
number 32. And thinking about the way
that we model complex systems and
generate approximations that sometimes
can also retain some other features,
like the highly optimistic exponent. So
some thoughts there, Bleu. So we've
definitely seen internal states and
sensory states like that reciprocality
happen, but I always wonder why,
especially since we did the mental
action paper, how action states
don't influence internal states. And so
for me, when you take action, like when
you practice playing the piano,
that affects your internal states
totally, not just through external
states or even mental action like where
you're doing nothing with external
states, it's entirely internal. And so I
always wonder why that action and
internal is there, but I less so
wonder why there's not a reciprocal loop
between external states and sensory
states. Like I never want the sensory
states to go back to the external
states. For me, that doesn't make sense.
And maybe you guys have an example where
it does make sense, but I always want
the action and internal states to loop
together to have it bi directional.
Here's one possibility on the sense back
to external, but it depends of course,
on a specific interpretation of those.
A photon. Let's just assume it's out
there. It hits the retina. If we talk
about the retina as a sense state,
using it very loosely, not the
statistical variable correlating to the
sense state, but the actual retina,
it's the absorption of the photon
that changes the niche to be sensed.
Like if you're going to be sensing
molecules from the ants cuticle, you
have to take some you could sense from
the ground the Ines that have already
been deposited. But if you want some
from the thing, you have to take a
sample. And so that may whether
that would be better understood as being
an action in the niche is another
question. But like you do have to change
the external state to be have skin in
the game. No, and I just thought of it
as you're saying that like the observer
phenomenon, right? So there's that too,
right? Just the act of sensing it chang.
Kim or is the observer phenomena, does
that come from sense? Does that come
from internal states? Does it come from
action states? Are the observers just
acting in a way that might fit in within
an action state? But those are really
interesting questions. Dean. No,
I just think you're right. I think both
of you we're
getting closer. I don't think we'll ever
fly directly into the sun, but we're
getting warmer. Yeah.
Cell have another few minutes to talk.
This has been a really great discussion
that I look forward to relistening to it
and discussing more. Then, of course,
feel so appreciative that we have a dot
two as well, so we
can return to some of our early ones
free will. Maybe save it for the dot
two. Or if we want to talk about it now,
I think we've blurred and fuzzed some of
these lines a little bit, so we did kind
of get there. Let's see what else we had
down. And of course, if anyone in the
last 30 minutes has any questions, they
want to write. So Stephen wrote, I like
your method to work backwards in the
flow diagram. Start at representative or
nonrepresentative assumptions, or
perhaps conclusions like starting at
those endpoints as assumptions, then
looking for prediction errors in our
action perception. This maintains
uncertainty in ways that does not happen
when following the causal effective
correlations.
That's sort of like 20 Questions is
framed as a game of, oh,
I'm sorry, I didn't know that mentioning
common children's games was funny.
That's framed as a game of going from
the most uncertain towards more
certainty. Like if you were asking
uninformative questions,
what are you doing? If you're just
getting and that's information theory
kind of exemplified you're reducing the
set of what you can be guessing
with the preference to win within 20
questions. And then this is, as Steven
is pointing out, kind of the other
dimension. But then what does that look
like? And that is almost inflating
uncertainty, at least in the information
theory sense. So here's Stephen's
question and then either of you, if you
have a thought on this, do we model the
temporal DAGs in dynamical change
between sensory state in relation to
changes in action state?
So maybe a related question would be how
do active states and temporal lags play
into our modeling of action
exteroception and cognition?
That's why I kept saying, young people,
when in doubt, zoom in, zoom out. And it
wasn't just zoom in, zoom out in a sort
of in a visual sense.
You have to zoom in and zoom out on a
temporal sense as well.
You have to think about the unit of
analysis both as an
object, but also as
the length of time if something can
remain stable or not.
I don't think we're naturally inclined
to include the time frame as much as
we're inclined to include the did it
chang kim, it float, did it burn?
Whatever it is that we're waiting to see
what happens next, we don't tend to give
as much attention over to how long did
it take?
I'll give a complimentary thought,
which is more related to the kinds of
models that we've specifically seen in
ActInf Lab, the deep temporal models or
sophisticated active inference in, for
example, a three time step model. At
timestep one, it's doing inference. On
one, two, and three, that's learning as
inference in anticipation. At timestep
three, it can still be calculating the
model in light of incoming evidence
about time step one, two, and three,
which is related to memory and learning
and all these other sorts of socalled,
backwards looking types of inference.
So there's like, anticipation, there's
now casting, and then there's
reconstruction of your recent and long
term past and how that's related to
identity. So I think the question do
we or how do we model the temporal or
just the temporality of sense and action
states? The answer from model based
science is, what's the time horizon
parameter on the model that we ran? Oh,
it was 15 days. Okay, well, then we
modeled the temporal lag up to 15
days, and that is what we modeled.
And that is sort of where the
scale free becomes the scale friendly,
becomes the scale specific, and then
that's the most that it contracts down
to is that one specific model as
deployed by those researchers.
Here's another question from Stephen.
When do we sense and when do we act?
When do our sense states update? When
does our generative models update, and
when do our action states update? I'll
start with the model based science one,
which is again, it would just be the
specifics of how the pseudocode and the
actual computer code were written.
Which line of code updates first?
That's the narrow answer. But what about
a more broader answer?
Does it depend on how open we are,
how confident we are in
staying in an uncertain, nonspecific
space? And can we necessarily know going
in how long that will be?
I don't know. I don't know how long.
And what about cognition, right? Like,
if we expand to that possibility,
I knew that was going to happen. I mean,
that happens to all of us. We all
emergence. That like, oh, I knew that
was going to happen. Like, if I step on
this ice cube, it's going to like this
ice pile, it's going to crack through to
water or whatever. I knew that was going
to happen. So we're able to kind of
perceive things before they happen. And
so I don't know, is there not
necessarily the temporal separation?
This makes me think back to, like,
Shannon Dobson and like, the flattening
of the time diamond, right? So really,
like, is it necessary
that there is sequence here or can it
just all be happening simultaneously?
That kind of relates to what I was
asking earlier to you. Is there some
kind of simultaneous update sensing
action possibility? And I think that
there is. I mean, I don't think that not
in a computational model because code
just runs like it is, but I think in
our model it's possible. Yeah.
Okay, one more general and then more
specific comment. The 4D spatial model
tetrahedral cybernetics geometry. You
have space and time, four dimensions
spatially represented rather than the
XYZ. You have three spatial dimensions.
And then there's like, the special
question of how does t come into play.
So some is known there and some is not
known there, but when and where and how
are of course very linked. And if we
take model based science seriously,
then they're also very enabled and
constrained by the kinds of models we
have. So maybe it's related to how we
think about geometry and then the
sense and action.
Are they continuous or are they
discrete? We've Dean Decety Costa
at all like the synthesis of active
inference on discrete state spaces and
then we've also seen some of Alex
Shance's work on the continuous control
settings with like the mountain car,
which is not just the discrete case.
So it's just interesting to see how some
of the theory goes out in front and then
there's parallel Ines of mathematical
development with continuous and discrete
modeling like digital and analog
modeling. And sometimes those types of
modeling scientifically are very well
reconciled and other times they result
in pretty fundamentally different
patterns. Like there are certain
equations where the discretized form or
the version that's computed without
really high precision numbers on a
computer has really different behavior
than the other kinds of models, which
gets at the importance of thinking about
how the model is framed and then also
applied. Because, like if the precision
of the processor matters for what the
paper discovers, then shouldn't that be
a part of the consideration?
Yeah.
Okay, here's a few of the other comments
for by the way we'll write down any
other questions. So if anyone in the
last few minutes has some questions they
can ask and we'll be just writing things
down, getting excited for dot two and
if anybody wants to join who wasn't here
today, they're also very welcome too.
How is representation related to
autopoeysis? So refresher autopoetic
system is capable of producing and
maintaining itself by creating its own
parts. So how does representation
differ? Or does it differ for a system
that is just engineered and secreted
into the niche like a computer versus
potentially something that is
reassembling its parts continually? Why
does that matter if it does?
Is that a thing to look at in .2?
Daniel, that sounds good. I'm not trying
to push it on, but I mean, the reality
is that we can take each of the
different segments, the organizational,
the structural, the content related,
and then put them through the auto
poetic grinder and
see what pops out the other side. Okay,
great suggestion. Apply this to the four
columns.
What other things would be fun to
discuss in dot two or what
else can go through the four column
grinder? Or what would be any other
question that any of you have.
In the .2? Also we can
spend a little bit of time on some
of the comments that were in the action
five of the paper, specifically around
how we face state from potentially
they didn't say that this is true, but
they said if this claim is true. We
could be faced from non
representational, internal
representation, maybe. Could we spend a
little bit of time not just looking at
the autopoesis aspect of that, but how
does that density form in relationship
to this idea of modeling ourselves?
Great question. Here's a question that
Steven wrote. So feel free to give a
thought on it. Or we can push it.
It was will robotics or
neuro phenomenology help most in testing
these complex temporal dynamics in a
realist way?
I'm just going to say that's a great
question and I think we need the person
who asked the question to come on and
chat with us about that a little bit.
We're just delegating so hard here.
Bleu, go ahead. So something
that I've brought up, I think in the dot
zero is like I would really like to
tease apart the similarities and
differences between structural aspects
and content related aspects.
I'm not entirely certain, like, that's a
fuzzy, blurred line for me there.
So maybe we could get into that a little
bit more. I agree. It's fuzzy for me
too. These are awesome questions too.
Thanks for learning it's all. Bleu cell.
We have multiple pages. We have auto
policies from non
rep to rep and back and forth, whatever
else. How does that form in the concept
of self representation? I think there's
a few Hamlet quotes that will come into
play there. Then Stevens question about
technology and realism,
structural and content action,
action oriented representation. The
neurobehavioral systems in the sensory
motor loop,
niche modification, stigma g and the
digital case, extended cognitive systems
that include digital and mirror
active klaas.
Stephan singing 80 songs in the chat, I
believe. Thinking through other minds
and multi scale integration. One of
Simpsons other papers. How are they
related? Does the FEP exist
independently or only in the mirror?
Lot of ways to answer that one.
One part we could look into now
or maybe in the dot two would be the
free expected free energy and
variational. Free energy and how they
play different roles in the FEP.
These are also some things, like if
people are watching live or in the next
few DAGs, then they can write a comment
on it or get in touch with us. Like if
they want to submit a question or they
can come on and discuss it in the dot
two too. Variational and expected
free energy. There's a lot
of parts to the paper and action
oriented representation, we didn't get
to that slide in the dot zero, but just
what is action oriented representation?
We've talked internal representation
today, but then did we talk about where
we implicitly talking about action
oriented representations? Are those a
sub class? How are they different.
In our system? In human cognition,
there are some hard coded
representations that we have,
like actionoriented, maybe one of them
like kinesthetic memory and also like
visual recognition systems. And it's
really interesting that and perhaps
easy to apply the FEP to
specific cognitive systems like
subsystems. But it's
really much more difficult when we have
multiple competing processes. Like we're
not just playing the piano and we're not
just looking at the piano keys. We're
doing both of those things at the same
time and lots of other things. Like we
might be, you know, having some memory
of one time that we heard the song that
we're playing or something like that.
So it's really interesting to think
about representation and all the ways
that it exists also even in memory,
right? Like the memory representation
not a hard coded thing.
It's really squishy and it's subject to
change through time. And we might
remember a situation like you can tell
me your phone number right now and I'll
remember it in five minutes, but in five
days, no, or something like that. So I
don't know. It's really interesting to
think about the FEP and how it can apply
in this overarching way where there are
multiple computing goals and priorities.
One thought I hope I'm not
misrepresenting an empirical result was
in fruit fly the Drosophila. They found
that shortterm memories didn't require
protein synthesis like just second to
seconds. Some sound or some symbol could
be associated with a preferred or
repulsive outcome. But preventing
protein synthesis block the
consolidation of memory and perhaps
that's similar to other systems. And so
there's kind of like the resonant neural
structures that are just using the
system's connections as they are.
That's sort of one perhaps faster mode
of cognition that's like running around
figure two. And then there's a
restructuring that requires changing
the model like structure learning. But
that also connects to realism because
we're talking about the synapses and the
neurogenesis like of specific cells that
could be maybe measured and then the
neurophysiology and the behavior can be
observed as well. If we have
interoceptive framework like Active,
it also relates to Dean's comment about
the scales the Timescales will Chang Kim
neural circuits cannot be changing at a
time scale faster than neural firing.
So how does the spiking component or the
other sensory transduction or other
chemical components, how do those
overlapping active states coordinate?
This reminds me to Daniel of something
that we talked about, like the very
first time we met because it was a
recent experiment at that time about the
memory transfer between snails via
interactions of RNA. So that was
like an interesting possible memory
storage and I'm not sure what else has
developed from that. But also we've
talked about ants and how
they leave. Like, you told me that
they're just throwing up RNA, like
they're throwing up all the time all
over the place and maybe leaving
chemical RNA traces for each other. We
talked about that too. So maybe I don't
know if you want to expand on that or
does that tie into this protein
synthesis thing.
One, I found that it was a recent ant
paper where basically the act of mating,
which we won't describe on this
familyfriendly discussion directly,
infuses neurotransmitters into the
recipient, and that changes their
behavior and induces all these other
hormonal changes. And so the realism of
cognition, like the embodiment and the
physicality of these systems, it is
perturbable by infusions of
neurotransmitters in other neural
systems and in us. So that's sort of
where realism can't be eradicated amidst
all of these representations because
things do hit our head and molecules do
diffuse it's, kind of like grounding it.
And that's, I think, why it's such an
interesting and integrative area with
a lot of contention, because the four E
side is holding down that real side
and then the science side, socalled, is
holding down the abstractions and the
representations. And then cognitive
science especially is applied to humans
is kind of where it meets in the middle.
It's like, well, yeah, you're talking
about embedded cognition and active
cognition, but that's your cognition
that's modeling. And so then you get
all kinds of fun viewpoints and ideas
because of how mixed
and complex that area is.
Thanks Bleu and Dean and those who
participated in Chat for this really
great discussion. I hope you can
digest it and learn in the next week and
reflect on some of these questions. And
anyone can ask more questions or start
to prepare some thoughts so that they
can also be involved, because this is
really fun. All right,
one question. Yes. Statement.
Every one of these live streams. I don't
know ultimately how it's decided which
order that we do them in, but the fact
that we've gone from Connor's paper to
Madiz paper to this one, whether it was
done with some sort of intent and
looking back to the future or it was
just, okay, well, I think we'll do this
one next and see what happens. I think
the order of these last free papers in
particular has been pretty
just. The order in which we've looked at
them has generated a whole bunch of
interesting ideas, including sort of
the idea of intransitivity in the last
paper now potentially influencing how
we've discussed this paper. So, again,
I don't know how much prethought goes
into that, but if there was some
prethought that went into putting these
papers in this particular order,
it's been very helpful. And one
other thing. If I find something
happy because it's true, I'm going to
laugh. And if I find something happy
because it's playing a game like 20
Questions or any game, I'm going to
laugh. So if I can't be if
I can't enjoy and really
appreciate the sophistication of the
conversation here, I probably wouldn't
show up. So thanks to both of you. You
can make me read academic papers, but
you can't make me have fun. But just to
give it one closing answer information
for anybody who wants to get involved
with the discussions, here's our Coda
for the.com unit. And so here's the live
stream table, the one that gets
represented on The Viewable, public one.
So we have all the papers planned, like
in this case up till 373-8394 up
through the end of March. So we try to
plan the papers in advance so that
people can have time to read them and
commit to collaborating on the Dot zero
background video. And then we have
papers to potentially discuss. And so
here people add papers and then they
click a heart. And Dean, we just sorted
by hearts and then we picked the papers
that were on the four top papers and we
said, okay, we're going to read these
four for 36, seven, eight, nine,
those. And then we emailed the authors
and so we have different papers and we
said Cell, what dates might work,
because we always will prefer to
schedule a paper that we want to read
when the authors want to join. And so
that's kind of our first, like the way
that we pull papers out, like we set the
dates for the Quantum Free Energy
discussions in March and then we work
backwards from there. And then just try
to not do two,
not even overlapping papers, just try to
provide rhythm and novelty and
philosophy and technical details. So
it's sort of a local decision making
based upon the votes that people provide
who are participating in the.com unit.
And pretty random. Yeah. And just what
people surface? I was going to say
that's a pretty serendipitous order then
that's fantastic. It's fine. And if
anybody watching or listening wants to
suggest a paper for the Livestream,
please do so. Yeah, alright.
Thank you, Dean. And Bleu. So see you
all next week for the Dot two.